[Music]
so this week we've got tree mail sea
lion snatch and topless thief
take it away Tiffany - the word you saw
I take on day shock Lorraine
Melvin has assigned an email address to
all 77,000 trees in their City
whoa how you gonna get a tree mail yeah
I counted all the trees I saw that I did
yes can be in a group or you must love
it because you love nature and the 70
how many times did he [ __ ] up - in the
color I like 5605 what I told you not to
[ __ ] talk to me what start all over
again 3 I hope they had a good system
like I would just tag each tree like I
would just give a number for it I'm sure
they probably did too and then when the
numbers run out I go ok that's many
7,000 times you gotta do this we also
got out counts of tags first 77,000 tags
make sure they all match well this is
just a Sun pretty look I love like in
your world no computer or technologies I
know when no baby I'll do it at though
you know what he go to the bank and
withdraw hella money they do though and
then after to take it out just to show
you yeah that's what a camera that's the
reason why they do it just to show you
that's really been counted by technology
yet if I'm a tree [ __ ]
they gotta count the trees in front of
me I want to see that time lapse
security footage of this guy with one
minute all of this kind of in one city
this guy in the middle of a show just
crying you gotta go all over the city -
it's not just like all in one place like
a forest because you know like a forest
all the trees on one side and on the
humans on the other side is there a
major issue of deforestation in
Melbourne yeah what's the point of this
yeah why the trees need to get an email
but something bad on email you do well -
tree yeah you are listen Angie oh oh
they got the email I tell you laugh at
it with the whole fudging this whole
thing yeah no I had mail why the trees
get an email so the reason why the city
people tree and email is so they said
it's this thing must be [ __ ] dumb
do you want to answer your question let
me tell you what answer different trees
can't go on Gmail
they can't type so those traditions of
that cities can report if there's a
specific tree that they see is that has
been vandalized or is on the decline
because they've been having a thirteen
year drought so it's affecting or not I
mean here's what the [ __ ] yeah so it's
affecting a lot of the trees around and
so what they did is they set up this
city map just like us so it's just part
of their urban forest strategy and so
this is what it looks like so you could
click anywhere around the map and each
light that you see here so all the
Greens mean that the trees are like
perfectly fine that they still have a
long way to go all like the orange and
the red means that they're slowly dying
because of many reasons and so if you
like boom in like let's say you want to
email a particular tree that's in front
of your house it's all the trees by the
road yeah so it's all of the trees and
so it gives you a little leap so tells
you what kind of tree it is the life
expectancy of the tree ID number and
then a little link for you to click on
it will lead you to your emails and
that's how you can use it already on the
solution for this you just got to make
every red light
a homeless piezo so you tell all the
homeless people to go pee on these
[ __ ] trees BIOS that's going to kill
the tree the fertilizer when you pee
into kids no fertilizers on most what
that is the ammonia becomes a nitrate in
the soil and it feeds the it burns the
roots an adult this does that
human [ __ ] we homeless Pope that's
fertilizer so close to human food [ __ ]
we're gonna have a pile of human [ __ ]
right next to these trees but they're
going to be healthy because we had the
juiciest [ __ ] fruits from three
dogs pissin in my backyard you know I
agree with you though poop on there too
right
we scoop the poop away that's exactly
what my mom did you like so we have like
a tangerine tree and like your old
favorite whispering spoon and then there
are parts of it were like some of the
branches would like kind of like tube
down and so one particular dog of ours
always likes to pee on this particular
branch and that branch grew like the
biggest tangerines and it was the
sweetest Henry I gotta see some sign to
the side be central to Chinese people no
I don't know so the ammonia gets into
the dirt gets converted to nitrate which
is nh3 and it gets absorbed through the
plant
whoa you know why you know why it's not
good it's because of the amount of how
much pee goes on on a daily basis then
it it's like too much vitamins it's kind
of like that it burns it I don't know I
never heard of pea fertilizer I heard
[ __ ] though I'm pretty sure there's some
farmers out there that normal stuff yeah
I'm pretty sure you just can't pee and
[ __ ] directly on the tree not honestly
you guys on the soil I try on a food
surface I know there's some processing
though because I've seen compost [ __ ]
where they put like bunch of old like
fruits and [ __ ] and they put it in there
and they put caca and they put a bunch
of worms and then they process that [ __ ]
and you could put that in there I think
you got to do that
I like how we just did entertain is
[ __ ] stupid idea now we sound stupid
or trying to figure out how to really do
that but you know cuz I'm confused
because I'm like wait how come you can
[ __ ] on it but you can't pee on it I'm
telling you right now all I know is that
fruit stopped growing on trees after yep
my fruit trees has a lifespan it's kind
of like a woman's ovaries I just gotta
say stuff that I know for a fact is real
and that that's one of them the guy is
definitely blue if not blue you know
oxygen Oh
I'm Korean are you are you so the
purpose of using my dress is work for
people to report as these trees were
vandalized as they were dying but what
they found out is that a lot of these
people that were emailing these trees
they're emailing them more like love
letters all come on yeah there are such
people will do for an example here's why
I would I love you take those people
that have that condition where they're
like in love with an inanimate object yo
I heard the plants do react to me do go
right I was sub bean jelly bean sprout
no keep Rome bean sprout all energy and
it comes out with westsides and [ __ ]
like this the [ __ ] branches what's
not much that's why your plants are
dying you don't give them any love
you'll talk to them enough sweet-talk
them they already came back to life when
I came back did you tell them hey baby I
miss you you know
you know what though sometimes when
people tell you how to take care of
plants is completely wrong I had these
succulents right that I got Oh No wild
it so here's the thing I they told me
how most lots of water than twice a
month right and that's all you have to
do and there's another pot a succulent
plant now if you spray and every day and
it's fine
[ __ ] last week they were dying and I
looked at them and all not a all in
sunlight they're all [ __ ] shriveled
and [ __ ] I don't think it's twice a week
so I started water them every four or
five days right those [ __ ] got
plump and juicy again another all good
[ __ ] lie to me man such a mess aren't
as easy as people so tell me there
they're actually a little bit more
difficult than expected
anyways plant right yeah so an example
of these love letters it says hello
weeping Myrtle I'm sitting inside near
you and I noticed on the urban tree map
you don't have any friends nearby I
think that said I want you to know I'm
thinking of you I also want to thank you
for providing oxygen for us to breathe
in the hustle and bustle of the city
that's regards and you don't want morals
gonna say back to it
I'm dying [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is this
letter give me some [ __ ] water
that's what mortals murdered over okay
oh my god that's a genius idea
that's all whoever's reading this they
just have to reply as a tree come and
water me so no one has to do the work
I'm hungry I'm so thirsty but there's a
lack of water so that's this yeah yeah
you can't even fix that if you want
that's all you gotta go homeless piss
it's perfect all pee no water
nutrient-packed
pee pee I've right next sorry this
little girl in Canada got dragged into
the water by Sheila I saw this and
that's what they these are when you [ __ ]
with mother nature but they were [ __ ]
they were they're just saying hi hi ha
you can't be all friendly though if you
see what don't you see did I do that yes
you would keep your distance though like
I think you're cute as [ __ ] I don't be
like hi you know we would all be [ __ ]
what the animal if it was coming up so
it would be like hi animal who went up
for the turtle detective in a why not me
because I'm like [ __ ] animal I
don't know what they're capable of none
of us said Oh Turtles uh-huh Apple
thought I was a turtle oh yeah you said
the turtle feels like Moby
I don't know I'm talking about so I'm
not going to show you guys the full
original video I just trimmed it for
tiny little clips it's only 15 seconds
this is pretty amazing though that's all
you need here we go
hey come here come here come on it's not
a little girl you were asking for it
dude that's [ __ ] crazy
Oh what oh what a good dad so we don't
know anything about his family it was
just the guy that uploaded the video
didn't know this family so if you just
uploaded it tweeted it and they went
viral
you did a kid's Paul or lover it's never
the kids fault
no kids don't know anybody that's the
parents fault yeah the guardians about
this yeah the parents should have
[ __ ] punched that feel when it came
up ah I said a longer way I should have
walked away they got a warning they got
that but there's a warning but I can't
even call I think it's not a dog it's
still a wild at seven SeaWorld it's big
it swam up to the dock like it's a wild
an amine zit hungry it's kind of like a
Fisherman's Wharf an SF this happened in
Canada wait it's like something similar
where there's the seals and like I feel
like this fear just wanted to play you
just wanted to play
yeah I think this ain't gonna eat people
yeah oh you wanna play - lets play
Palace doctor you responded instantly I
know that he definitely not what I would
have done like streaming oh my god oh my
god I would have been like this boom
it's like well we just lost a good one
yeah this is like what do you want me to
do it to seal the Dexter seals element
that is home turf that's true well then
come up like you're [ __ ] all blood
you know close and go to a [ __ ]
territory that's looking pretty peaceful
I'm not you what if now's your daughter
mm that's a little bit [ __ ] I probably
said the bike is all my god or easy to
hold her would come on man you're
actually aging this old oh my god guy oh
hey that's a good impersonation of a
white American hahaha oh my god oh my
god yeah good god yes now they kind of
sign morning long but I want to feel
yeah basically I'm glad that the little
girl didn't hit her head on a rock on
the way down you know rocks everywhere
just she could've used them at all like
the back of her head and crack it open
so fabulously let go to because then
which makes me wonder I don't know what
he was trying to explain is plain I
think because they were playing with
them back and forth and like the other
clips I think you were just like oh well
let's just see if you could drum it was
like they're like dog see dogs to me
because they look like those because
they act like dogs both and they bark
like dogs yeah you know how they scratch
their back with the back of their head
it's [ __ ] hilarious they know how to
do a full [ __ ] fold and start
scratching the back it's like their
whole body goes like this
how's that scratching anything cuz it's
like scratching like this yeah skin on
like what is it can you imagine
scratching your body with your freakin
skull contain anything they wish they
had now I wonder she'll really like it
then when you scratch them probably one
eyebrow last story there
this woman who advertised her business
as a topless cleaning service but she
was arrested for Pokkiri Oh
underwear she still doesn't know what I
robbed early feeling under why do you
need a steal stuff when you're fully
moon exactly and how do I hide away
yeah I could make it were you stuff in
your vagina about good girls girls
undergarments are expensive although I
am just pricey sent really and I just
saw Monday we call it the [ __ ]
Valencia Victoria's Secret inside the
red PSD Chris parents are giving
Valencia's boyfriend
that's not Mariel like working through
trying to buy sites of you and they were
sittin like $40 for a bra some [ __ ] it
was something I can't remember the
number but it was like my purse on Elsa
how much is that [ __ ] maybe $40 I only
buy cheap lingerie on Amazon [ __ ] that
mm yeah this is the woman's business
flier that's the most gentle estate I've
ever seen I know this container lady
what oh [ __ ] laughs you actually want
out the middle like for her phone number
yeah but with someone like that I'm
imagining it's a really really nasty
looking person why like look at how
[ __ ] up they do that ghetto ass
writing like it's a [ __ ] bad ass
it's a dirty ass flier so I imagine the
person that does that is not clean yeah
no it doesn't pay attention to detail
yeah it's like a [ __ ] homeless
cardboard poster maybe she just had a
brilliant idea and she just had to get
it on paper and it was just like before
I forget this me just write this [ __ ]
out watching pot of hell
maybe she doesn't need a printer would
you have a picture of her maker
I'm just imagining if this is how she
presents herself in advertisement then
imagine how she presents herself in full
nude because isn't it the stereos you
work out that prettiest ones are the
ones that do
less yeah is that what it is I'm asking
ladies like section e problem like
they're the heart they play hard to get
I like your prove yes that's been the
stereo stereo I don't know if it's true
now that depends on the amount of money
I'd I ask yeah I think myself is that I
seen plenty of pretty girls on porn so
that's not a lot that's not true but
they do it for money bill okay it's not
there they're not they're not a [ __ ]
cuz it's doing it for money they do it
for a lot of money the porn stars now
he's different
yes funny cuz the police department
posted the story of this woman how they
caught her and like the whole but then
they were the way they wrote it was like
how I see her glory know I have photos
so in that story is the police
department's Facebook post if they wrote
she was arrested by officer dick Pope
saying yep that's really his name and
they just now it was really funny the
fact of the opposite his name is Dirk
any call a [ __ ] dude great Polk so
like big pool yeah oh I thought a big
poke or poke Oh Richard pokes the
clothes on would have suffered as a kid
I know it's so easy subject poke maybe
it's like having a name flatfoot
and you're a kid you don't want embrace
- yeah you just get made fun of when you
cry when you become a porn star uh-huh
or detectives I'm sorry hey guys thanks
for watching that last episode if you
haven't already make sure to hit that
subscribe button because we upload
videos every single day for you guys now
to watch more videos check them out of
here
[Music]